what up yo I'm Dave Rubin it is March
8th 2023 this is the Reuben part we are
live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
locals there will be no post game show
today I have my reasons but I will make
it up to you I promise you those of you
that are in the locals Community know
why there's no post game show today
already because of reasons of which I
described to you yesterday that's all I
have to say for the general public today
we are doing a locals Community Q a uh
but I wanted to frame it around the
State of the State of Florida which was
yesterday Governor Ron DeSantis given
the annual State of the State address uh
obviously this one had a particular sort
of uh poignancy to it a certain focus on
it because of what seemingly is
happening related to this whole
presidential run kind of thing again I
don't know anything that you don't know
but it all seems to be kind of going in
that direction the guy's just coming
back from a nationwide tour uh the
blueprint that Florida is trying to
export to the rest of the country and
much more so we're going to talk about
that with one little clip of CNN and Don
Lemon related to DeSantis and just the
pure propaganda that corporate media
just keeps spewing on us so that's on
the agenda today before we get to it let
me talk to you guys about Birch gold You
know despite the U.S blowing through the
31.4 trillion dollar debt ceiling in
January the leftist White House still
refuses to reduce spending while our
national leadership has buried their
heads in the sand when it comes to
fiscal responsibility it's time to pull
yours out now would be a great time to
diversify into gold with Birch gold in
times of high uncertainty and
instability gold is King it's Dependable
Birch gold makes it easy to convert an
IRA or 401K into an i RA in Precious
Metals here's what you got to do visit
birchgold.com Dave to claim your free
info kit on gold and then talk to one of
their precious metals Specialists think
about this to dig our country out of
this mountain of debt every single
taxpayer in America would have to write
a check for 247 Grand not really in the
mood to do that and it's only getting
worse guys protect yourself with gold
today by visiting birchgold.com Dave
they've got an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews you can trust birchgold
birchgold.com Dave today and now back to
me all right so I mostly want to focus
on the good stuff and the good stuff is
the State of the State and even if you
don't live in the Great the free state
of Florida it is good for you wherever
you live because this is the beacon of
Freedom this is the signal that is being
sent across the world right now of how
to do it right and when you
see someone doing it right you gotta
amplify it you got to help them that's
what I'm trying to do I think that's
what you're trying to do but the Liars
the frauds the con men and the bad
people will always try to quash that
sense of freedom because they love
control here's Don Lemon on his Morning
Show and as you know he was demoted to
the morning show because no one wanted
to watch him at night soon enough he'll
be on the 4 AM hour and then he'll
probably be wandering the Streets of San
Francisco after that but here he is he
brings on Ken Burns and you guys might
know Ken Burns Ken Burns is a very very
famous
documentarian he has done many many
documentaries over the years on baseball
and American history a whole bunch more
but basically has become a left-wing
Progressive pundit I don't know why they
ask him these questions related to
current events and what's happening
today but they do and here's Ken Burns
basically equating DeSantis to the Nazis
and the Soviets moved enough to write
about this bill and what's going on with
the whole idea of critical race Theory
and not teaching the full history of
this country why you know what makes
America great
is not the suppression of ideas or the
pursuit of every corner of those ideas
may lead us or the facts it's it's about
who we are and how we investigate who we
are and celebrate the diversity of who
we are all of these bills that DeSantis
and others are doing limit our ability
to understand who we are and are not
inclusive they're exclusive they're
they're narrowing the focus of what is
and isn't American history it's
terrifying it feels like a Soviet system
or you know the way the Nazis would
build a potemkin village Taco Carlson's
doing the same thing with the footage
from uh one six it's just a a kind of
rewriting of history at the most
dangerous level it's it's it's huge
threat to our Republic
you are a huge threat to our Republic
you clowns and hacks all right first off
one more time say it with me you know it
they are not removing African-American
history from the schools in Florida they
are taking away one AP course which was
going to teach woke gender Theory as it
relates to African-American history and
that has nothing to do with African
American history although I've often
asked the question was Harriet Tubman
running a secret underground railroad
that had something to do with lesbians I
don't know maybe that's what it was all
about but I would need to read more
there is nothing bigoted about this the
idea that you have to teach everything
in schools regardless of whether it's
true or good or just or right is
completely insane is the position that
these people are taking that Ken Burns
and lemon and the ladies are taking that
we should teach Nazism in school Nazism
is a political ideology based in a
racial Supremacy which actually is
pretty close to wokeness if you think
about it
um do they want to teach that I suspect
they don't want to teach that he also
just says it's just these generic
platitudes that mean nothing what makes
us great is Who We Are
what does that mean it's who we are
that's what makes us great and the other
one it's how we what makes us great is
how we celebrate diversity diversity is
not good in and of itself right uh if
diversity was good in and of itself
these people would like intellectual
diversity they would like the diversity
of ideas but that's the last thing they
like they like their ideas and for you
to sit down and shut up but don't take
my word for all of this because Governor
DeSantis gave his State of the State
yesterday and he knew exactly what the
media was going to do when he got rid of
this AP course which by the way everyone
in Florida agrees with and most of these
people actually do so here is DeSantis
oh first before we get to the state of
state so this is this is like two days
ago before the State of the State here
is this DeSantis responding to the
corporate media attack on this removal
of the AP course Governor DeSantis does
not want students to learn about slavery
and it's aftermath at well if you
actually looked at what our standards
are not only is it not prohibited to
teach that it's required to teach that
it's required to teach all of those
things it's required under Florida
Statutes to teach about racial
discrimination they're doing it because
they know there's enough people in
corporate media who will just take that
and we'll run with that so we've got all
these examples cataloged of basically
media lies to try to do to try to do the
hoax in Florida you know if it's
explicit and pornographic parents have
the right to object and it should be
taken off
and then in terms of issues involving
American history it's very clear in
Florida standards that we are required
to teach all aspects of black history
not queer Theory but actual aspects of
black history
all right so look he knew the attacks
were coming he has an incredibly
airtight team that knows how to deal
with these people we showed you the
video what two weeks ago Andrea Mitchell
of NBC News asking Kamala Harris what is
it that Ron DeSantis doesn't want people
knowing about about slavery and black
history what does Governor Ron DeSantis
not know a black about black history and
the black experience when he says that
slavery and the aftermath of slavery
should not be taught to Florida school
children these people lie about
everything Ken Burns is lying Don Lemon
is lying Andrea Mitchell is lying Anna
Navarro is lying Whoopi is lying they
lie about everything but DeSantis is
just going about the business of the
state and if you really want proof on
all of this they have these hysterical
outbursts about all of these things and
then what happens as time goes by and
people forget things nothing bad happens
because of the things that Ron DeSantis
is doing for example we checked in
Phoenix if you could fire up your
computer right now how many gay people
have been arrested in Florida since
don't say gay how many from the DeSantis
goon squad I got a big fat zero unless
were you just giving me the white
supremacist time no that was a zero okay
so that's one thing
um and we are as he said we are we do
have to teach black history so that of
course is a lie everything that they say
is a lie and what they are jealous of is
that people are waking up people are
understanding what freedom is people are
moving here they're leaving the crap
fact the crap Factory States I'm gonna
say craptastic or Crap Factory I combine
that into one thing
and it's all good here so here is
Governor DeSantis kicking off the State
of the State
Mr Speaker Madam president members of
the legislature and fellow citizens my
duty under the Constitution is to inform
the legislature concerning the condition
of the state and to recommend measures
in the public interest well as we used
to do in the military here's the bluff
the bottom line up front
Florida is number one and working
together we will ensure that Florida
Remains the number one state in these
United States
the guy is focused he's got a super
majority we're escalating infrastructure
projects because so many people are
moving here if you didn't see my I did a
mini interview with him last week just
15 or 18 minutes or so and we discussed
some of the things that he can do to
ensure that Florida not only will stay
free but stay flourishing as we get all
of these new people and one of the other
things that he's doing and somehow the
left will have a fit about this one too
he's going out of his way to make sure
it is easier to have children in Florida
that there are less barriers financially
and otherwise if you want to start a
family in the Free State of Florida
it will help many who need relief from
inflation especially our Florida
families by permanently eliminating
sales tax on all baby supplies diapers
wipes clothes crib strollers we will be
able to say that in Florida having a
child will be tax-free we are proud to
be pro-family and we are proud to be
pro-life in the state of Florida
you know it's a little unfortunate
because I got these two kids downstairs
but we already bought our strollers and
our crib so I'm screwed on that one I
paid state tax on that but we are buying
diapers and probably will be for quite
some time so I'm going to save a little
cash on that I do want to quickly
address the pro-life comment there
because obviously not every single
person in Florida is a hundred percent
pro-life the way Governor DeSantis
describes his own personal beliefs I
have been on stage with him when he has
been asked about this I was sitting next
to him at a event a couple months ago
and people asked him about his personal
beliefs on abortion versus the position
of the state and he said look I'm a
Catholic and that that frames my view on
this and I personally am pro-life he
said but I understand that I govern an
estate with many different people and we
feel that the 15-week ban on abortion
which is what we have in Florida right
now 15 weeks you know basically three
and a half months that that's quite deep
into a pregnancy that that is the right
thing and what's so interesting about
that is Florida which is now thought of
as this you know right wing red state
run by evil DeSantis and the fascists it
has a 15-week man on abortion which
every Democrat in America would have
said is a fair cut-off point 10 to 20
years ago Bill Clinton of 20 years ago
you know 15 to 20 weeks 20 was sort of
the max now the Democrats are at eight
and eight and a half month abortions
Cali wants you to have an abortion at
any point they literally are talking
about post-birth abortions where the
doctor and the the mother can decide
whether to kill the baby after the birth
I mean there's such crazy stuff so
Florida which is a pro-life state in
that in a certain sense has the most
moderate position so when they tell you
how far right this place is what you
should say to them is Oh you mean
moderate Democrat of 15 years ago uh
anyway he concluded his speech we could
have played a gajillion clips of it but
I'm sure we'll play some more uh you
know in the coming weeks as he lines up
what his agenda is and what this
blueprint actually stands for but he
concluded his address by doing something
that I think was really effective there
is going to be an awful lot of noise
right the noise is going to come from
every direction the the left the
corporate media all of that nonsense
they're going to try to destroy him
Trump the other opponents they're going
to try to destroy him but the guy is
focused on doing the right thing and
that was his message to the legislature
don't worry about the chattering class
ignore all the background noise keep the
compass set to True North we will stand
strong we will hold the line we won't
back down and I can promise you this
you ain't seen nothing yet thank you all
God bless you
thank you
gotta say guys it feels good to live in
a place that is governed by people who
are interested in Freedom and doing the
right thing and ignoring the noise and
fighting and saying enough is enough and
all of that stuff so if you're watching
this as a Reuben report viewer I welcome
you to move to Florida don't bring your
family that's not cool but you you can
come all right let's get to a
reubenreport.locals.com community Q and
A Paul says the Democrats are reducing
penalties for murder yeah that's true we
we discussed it a couple days ago I
cannot fathom this at the request of the
people who wants that do you think they
are doing this knowing that many of them
and their friends will soon be facing
some various serious charges is this
mitigation so every time the Democrats
come in with one of these idiotic things
we are not going to arrest you if you
jump a Turn Style we are not going to
arrest you if you're trespassing we are
going to lower penalties on murder and
armed robbery and all these things their
thought process let's try to give the
least cynical version all right let's
try to steal man their argument their
argument would be there is a set of
people who are aggrieved in society and
who have basically been forced into
doing really bad things and the system
is racist and oppressive against them
and they have to do these bad things so
when they say murder a family or push an
old lady into the Subway or break into a
Target to steal a TV that I suppose
they're going to eat because you know
okay fine
that we should not treat them so harshly
because it's it's in some way it's our
fault in a weird way we deserve it and
this would be they their belief of uh
good intentions however the road to hell
is paved with you know what and this is
what consistently happens so that's the
age-old debate it's like who's driving
the progressive machine you know who's
driving that car off the cliff and to
all the people in the back know what's
really going on do the people really
driving it like they would have to look
at basic evidence big government high
taxes a lot of handouts you destroy
cities like there's evidence everywhere
it's everywhere you don't even need more
studies or to read old Thomas Soul books
or anything else just go to any big city
go to New York where I was last week go
to Philadelphia San Francisco Los
Angeles Portland Seattle okay you know
it right go there and see do these
policies work
but it all sounds right
defund the police the police are kind of
mean and they they don't like black
people and even when five black cops act
you know kill a black guy somehow that's
racist and
so the question is is it the intentions
of all the people and then you just have
a bunch of useful idiots and what do you
do with that that is the combination
that I think we have and it and it's a
match made in hell I think you have a
small set of really bad people with bad
ideas and then you have a whole bunch of
mostly young people who haven't thought
through the issues but then I would say
there's another version of it which is
you could take someone which is a Bernie
Sanders type who I really believe is a
believer in this stuff like I don't
think he's faking it but after what
happened on real time that we played you
know we played that clip a couple times
where he did not know the difference
between equality and Equity that would
be like Sam do you know the difference
between socialism and capitalism do you
know the difference between baseball and
basketball this is your basic 101 stuff
and he didn't even know that so so
you've got useful idiots you've got
intentional morons you've you've got
just it's a clown car it is a clown car
with ain't where there ain't much good
in it snow baby says have either of the
boys started cutting teeth have you
started introducing them to solids my
baby was interested in Foods at four
months now almost one year devours
everything so nobody's on solid yet we
are we're still doing the breast milk
thing I've got a giant freezer of breast
milk with also one Wagyu steak that when
they are officially done with the breast
milk we will share our wagyu ribeye that
we've had in there for six or seven
months now but they are both well Justin
is in full teething mode which is why
the other day uh I told you when my eye
was a little screwed up he had scratched
me in the eye it's still like a little
irritated actually because you know
they're always just clawing at whatever
you can get and I try to let him do as
much as he wants to do if he wants to
just kind of grab around and pull my
hair or whatever they like kind of
rubbing on the beard
um
but I used his teething thing because
you know we've got all these teething
toys that you keep in the freezer
because they like that that coolness as
they're starting to teeth I was using
that on my eye to get the swelling to go
down uh anyway we think the tooth is
coming any day now he is a tooth is
coming could come by the end of this
sentence right now that's on the way
Luke will be a little bit behind him and
then we we've started the discussions
about how long we want to keep them on
the breast milk and before we move to
solids and everything because obviously
at this point it would be easier to move
to solids uh Dave great name Dave Dave
says in the fight to end the Deep State
cabal can anyone Trump well look that
question
is the best argument for Trump right
that he has been through the machine
they have thrown everything at him
impeachments and hearings and
investigations and all of the stuff he
has almost nothing else to play for
other than the thing that he's always
talking about which is draining the
swamp and all that and he has sort of
this there's a Vengeance to it this time
because he feels he was robbed last time
the whole election was fortified right
that was the big article in the Atlantic
after the election they didn't steal an
election they fortified an election
um so the question is can anyone do that
job better than Trump I don't know I
think it is perfect I think there is a
perfectly legit argument to say that
Trump would do that specific thing
perhaps more effectively than DeSantis
because he's been through part of it
right now he had all sorts of leaks he
didn't drain it a lot of it didn't work
out but some of it did we had a great
economy we had peace deals in the Middle
East like there was a lot of good there
too but I think there is an argument to
say that he would be the best at that if
at if it can be done at all now the
counter argument on the DeSantis side
would be like all right well DeSantis
basically believes the same thing right
he doesn't like the globalist he doesn't
like the wef he doesn't like the endless
bureaucracy he wants more term limits
for these people and he has a better
track record of actually accomplishing
specific things Trump's done a few big
things and they should not be discounted
for sure but DeSantis seems to have more
discipline a tighter team and he might
do it more effectively so I think you
can make arguments on either side for
that one uh Susan says I just finished
up watching the new Transformers movies
that were produced over the last decade
with my kids the one that is coming out
in June flips the story back to the 90s
and my son is highly disappointed my son
seems to think the Transformers will be
the next Star Wars franchise I know
you're a big transformers fan what do
you think look the Transformers movies
if you just watch them all first off you
must need a drink those things are such
like bludgeon hit you over the head with
a bat you don't know what's going on you
can't understand the Stories the last
one was the last one with the it was
like the the British they were in like
Knights of Camelot or something it was
so insane that if any I kid you not if
anyone in the locals Community can
explain to me in three sentences what
that movie was I will I will send you
five hundred dollars the movie was so
perplexing and psychotic and whatever
and they've all been terrible basically
the first one was kind of okay but they
are nothing in comparison have your son
watch the 1985 animated Transformers
movie I think I referenced it a couple
days ago on the show The Death of
Optimus Prime and of Starscream
Galvatron uh Robert Stack as
um not Rodimus Prime he was the other
guy like there's just so much goodness
there and the soundtrack is a great 80s
soundtrack and everything but Michael
Bay I mean he loves to make things
explode he likes to have very shiny
things you can't see anything there's no
story to him there's no cohesive
narrative they're just ugh it's just
disappointing flow Chuck says I'm not
for big government but do you think
there's anything that can be done policy
wise that could stop the blatant lying
from the media Outlets I think almost
all of America wants to repair the
country but it's hard to find a common
place to start when the media constantly
lie about what's going on yeah this is
in some ways that question gets to the
heart of what I'm doing on this show
more than anything else because I'm
always showing you clips of the media
and try and showing you how they should
be debunked in real time and that if we
don't do that you know on one hand we
can ignore it and just move on but then
you know a certain amount of people are
brainwashed on the other hand we don't
want to always waste our time talking
about the people who are doing
everything wrong but either way it puts
us in this Divergent path situation and
that's a problem look is there anything
that could be done at the governmental
level ah this is tough we have libel and
slander laws they are very very tight
and I don't know that you'd want to
tighten them you know over the years
Trump has talked about tightening them
and if you tighten them I would fear
that the chilling effect on Free Speech
would be a problem if if meaning if you
were to not tighten the loss if you were
to loosen them a little bit right so I
was giving you the reverse version of it
if you loosen these laws a little bit
and then suddenly more people can be
sued for Reliable and slander well I
make fun of people on this show all the
time usually in a sarcastic manner
hopefully in some level of wit and
witticism or whatever but I if the laws
were loosened a little bit and I felt I
could be sued well now I'm going to
self-censor we already have enough
self-centering right everyone's doing it
to themselves we already have
self-censoring related to what videos
put on YouTube and what gets demonetized
and everything else so I don't know that
there's much that can be done at the
state level I think maybe maybe there's
a way to do something specifically to
news outlets so if you're I don't know
what the exact accreditation is but
let's say you're a news channel you know
on on a cable network or your a
newspaper with a certain circulation
that there should be some law passed
that you have to you have to have a
certain standard of journalists
integrity
but again these are these are tough
things I think we're just going to all
keep going off in our own directions and
hopefully
you know the truth has a way of bubbling
up and I I think we all have to just
hold that with us and and believe that
that the truth will will shine through I
think that probably is it uh Dr weingine
says hey Dave as a successful business
owner and entrepreneur what would be
your biggest recommendation for those
who are thinking about opening their own
business well first off I mean this is
silly and cliche but just do it
just do it I didn't know what I was
doing when we went independent with the
Reuben report and we started the
production company and we left our jobs
in health insurance and we did it
several times it wasn't just when I left
The Young Turks then we left patreon uh
then we were renting a studio then I
thought we have to own our own Studio
like we did this many times then we
started local so I started the tech
company like all of these things it was
just a matter of like there's a problem
like let me just do it and you know the
I did it so many times that the last two
or three times that I've done it I was
like here we go one more time and then
in my head now even now I'm always like
is there one more in me like is there
one more crazy move in me you know and
there probably is actually I have no
doubt that there is there will be
probably one if not two or three more
crazy moves along the line like I will
always I I I've come to enjoy the
business part of it which is really
weird I never thought of myself as a
businessman I don't like sitting there
you know crunching numbers and I have
business manager and accountants that do
that kind of stuff but building things
that are good building a successful
production company that you know puts on
this show that hires these guys that I'm
proud of the content we put out and that
I own it and control it and can get it
out to you in a way that I think is
effective and all those things is is so
beautiful and then on the on the locals
front ultimately merging with Rumble
putting these things together and then
and then fighting for what I think is
the most important thing which is Free
Speech which is exactly what we're doing
and we're on the
the front end of that fight and it's a
really really beautiful thing and I'm
honored to be part of it so I would say
just do it and if you believe in it I
would say this to anything if you
believe in what you are doing do not
stop
again it sounds kind of cliche like you
want some kind of like granular business
information like don't forget to carry
the one I can't give you that kind of
advice but if you believe that what you
are doing is good whatever it is whether
you're making a freaking lollipop or
you're talking for a living or you want
to start a dental practice whatever it
might be if you are good at it and you
love it and you believe in it you will
find a way I worked an awful lot of odd
jobs I I lived in crappy Apartments I I
was broke at times scratching change
together get a cup of coffee literally
but now I'm not and I think that that
was just I just believe that if I kept
doing it that really is it it's
something I've said regards to Jordan
Peterson like I belief was built in I
didn't even realize it at the time but
belief was built in I believed that if I
gave something everything I got I would
get there
at one time I wanted to host the Tonight
Show well I'm not doing that although I
do watch the old Carson Tonight Show as
you guys know I'm not doing that but I'm
doing something pretty close and I think
the proof is in the puddin Tali says
Dave an actual serious question
regarding social media who would you say
are the top people other than yourself
who in conservative media tend to get
things right a majority of the time and
who are the ones you would say are the
most suspect oh you want me to name
names he'll name names uh well how about
I give credit to one guy who I often
give credit to when he joins us for the
Friday panel but Jeffrey Tucker who if
you have not seen him on this show you
got to check out Jeffrey Tucker he was
so right from day one on Covert now he's
a he's a Libertarian Economist so he's
not a traditional conservative in that
sense but he was so right about
lockdowns he was so right about mandates
and vaxes and all of the stuff I mean
from day one I was right pretty early on
I would say a few weeks in and as I
always say everyone's got a couple week
window on that thing you won't have it
the next time like the next time it
comes to down if you get fooled again
now it's on you but we so many of us for
a gajillion reasons all got fooled this
last time
um but he did not get fooled so I give
him a massive amount of credit I would
say other people who have been
directionally right about almost
everything I mean Jordan Peterson I
think has been directionally right about
almost everything he did get the vaccine
and uh you know he I grant him a little
bit of a leash on that because he was
very very sick and M.I.A for a while uh
so I don't think he was like fully fully
in you know Primo Jordan Peterson mode
um oh by the way speaking of Jordan
Peterson what can I say this
um there might be something happening
tomorrow night that's all I'll say for
now
um but uh so I would say Jordan has been
directionally right about what the real
threats are and alerting people to it I
would say James Lindsay who obviously
I've had on a bunch of times also has
really nailed most of these things and
gotten them right as for as for the
people who've really gotten things wrong
I mean
I don't want to throw anybody under the
bus that I that I like look we all make
mistakes we all screw up things I would
say look I like Ben a lot I would say
you know Ben Shapiro he did screw up to
some extent on the vaccines because he
was repeating a lot of the data the
quote-unquote data from the CDC and the
NIH and everything else related to
vaccines and he I think he had one tweet
where he said it was something it was
like a long threaded it ended something
like in short get the vaccine morons or
something like that maybe it wasn't
morons but it was a word like that and I
remember reading that thing like I just
don't believe all this nonsense and I
don't think that as a relatively young
healthy person who takes care of myself
and gets some sunlight and tries to
exercise that I need to worry about this
stuff so
whatever we all we all miss some here
and there uh BBG says I learned from my
time in DC that many protesters are not
actually in it for an issue but are
professionals uh I.E paid to protest
antifa members have the military have
military police grade equipment who is
paying for all this I mean my guess is
there is some Soros connection to ngos
that are training these people it's also
why the media the way they talk about
antifa is so ridiculous it's like antifa
had the Summer of Love burning down our
cities they just had a massive attack on
a police training facility in Atlanta
you're not seeing that on mainstream
media check it out on on rumble or
YouTube if you want to find some videos
on it
um but these people do seem very
coordinated they know when to attack
they know when to move forward and
retreat they use these little flash
bombs and occasionally Molotov cocktails
they had the Portland what was it the
Portland State house uh under a lockdown
for like a year during the summer of
love like there is something more
coordinated there I I believe there is
money there and and you know it it was
the Federal Courthouse in Portland
actually and and the thing is you know
it because they can turn it on and shut
it off whenever they want meaning let's
say that the movement behind BLM was
legit let's just say it it wasn't but
let's just say it was how is it that
they protested for two years under Trump
and then the second you know we had
people out in the streets and it was
coveted but you could as Lori Lightfoot
said you could take your mask off for
that because it's another sort of Health
that racism is another sort of health
emergency but then the second Biden
takes over there's no more BLM there's
no more rioting there's no more people
in the streets like there is some level
of coordination and you know it because
the media always tells you there's no
coordination so if the media tells you
that there's nothing then there's
obviously something Amy Says are there
any movies coming out this year that
you're looking forward to seeing
not really you know I didn't see Avatar
too I would like to see it I would like
to see it It's just tough getting out
with the kids right now so I would like
to see it I've heard some mixed things
but I enjoy the first one and you know
James Cameron is a great director and in
terms of the Innovation with cameras and
technology and all that kind of stuff
and and I you know I'm a big sci-fi guy
in general is there anything you guys
want to see like the movies even come
out anymore
do they make movies anymore
we have no wreck no one has a
recollection of them you guys remember
movies you'd go to this big room with
this theater and they'd give you popcorn
and you know that the butter that they
put on that popcorn has uh I don't know
that they do it anymore we used to pump
your own which I always felt you know
very libertarian but I never felt we
should be allowed to pump our own butter
it has something that causes Alzheimer's
in it and then we wonder why we have a
generation of brain dead morons Todd
says assuming the next wave of
politicians continue to flip seats red
and the Republican and a republican is
elected to the presidency how long do
you think it would take for things to
get even remotely close to what it was
before covid
it's a good question well let's put it
this way
the states are the states right the red
states are going to get redder the blue
states are going to get Bluer the
question is can we flip a couple can we
get a Colorado to go from Blue to red
right like there's a couple in the
middle that are kind of bouncing back
and forth and can those go a certain way
but let's say we got the santis in
and he started putting a hatchet to some
of the bureaucracy he started empowering
the states to actually abide by the law
and and do things with the federal
government that should be done and also
maybe and this is why I'm saying to
Santa this not Trump maybe because it
was DeSantis he gets these crossover
people who then can push back a little
bit against the radicals the problem is
that if Trump gets in the radicals are
going to be emboldened like crazy now
that's not Trump's fault but he triggers
these radicals okay and and then the
radicals run the asylum on the left we
know that right the inmates are running
the Asylum over there so I think descent
is probably as president would have a
better chance to say look here's what I
did in Florida the proof is in the
pudding Florida's flourishing how can I
now apply that so the states can do most
of the work which is the way it's
supposed to be and that the federal
government can just kind of slim itself
down and do the limited things that it's
supposed to be doing like who I guess
it's this who do you think at the end of
the day could get more border security
actually accomplished do you think it's
Trump who unfortunately was unable to do
it it was better than it was now and
then I fully blame the Democrats for it
there's many videos of of Schumer and
Pelosi saying they would not negotiate
at all because they didn't want to give
Trump any win or do you think DeSantis
who seems to be a better political
operative do you think he might be able
to get a little more done and I think
that that's what many of us are going to
have to decide when when we have to vote
in primaries if if it ends up being the
two of them Holly says are you going to
invite Crowder to the studio since he's
in Florida today as well I believe
Crowder is in Sarasota at the moment but
I don't know that I can say anything
else I think he might be with Russell
Brand I think I've said too much I think
that will move to the next question chef
says do you and David get date night or
are you homebodies I mean right now
we're home bodies like we are home
freaking bodies it's a lot of cooking
I'm doing all the cooking these days
because he's just on overload mode with
the kids but it's all good it's really
been very nice and you know now the kids
are going to bed at about 7 30. so from
7 30 you know till about 7 A.M when it
starts up all over again and it just
every day it starts up again it's wild
um you know then then we can just kind
of hang and watch a little TV or
something but mostly we're like passing
out on the couch and you know like a
little daily recap he's like how was the
show today I'm like good it's like how
are the kids good okay nice talking to
you
um
yeah we haven't had a date night or gone
out in a while but uh one of these days
I imagine we would go out again but we
still we still host a lot of dinners
here and that sort of thing we've guests
coming constantly in family and all that
so it's all good uh prosky says after
the questioning of Merrick Garland do
you think he'll be held accountable for
anything no not really
you guys know it you know they have
these hearings nothing really happens so
then you might go all right well then
why cover the hearings if nothing ever
comes of it if people if fauci can lie
under oath if Jack Dorsey can lie under
oath well I think getting the truth out
is still good regardless because over
time even if they don't prosecute these
people and fauci I certainly think
should be prosecuted but even if they
don't get some of these people and
they're not arrested or put behind bars
or thrown in the gulag or whatever it is
more and more people can wake up to the
nonsense right so when fauci testifies
no I was never for school lockdowns and
then you show people videos of fauci
being like I'm for school lockdowns you
can start exposing more of the nonsense
and that really is the game and and you
know there is a piece of me as much as I
would love to see somebody pay for what
happened during Kobe like the people who
really really screwed up and I put fauji
at the top of that list it's like you
don't want to end up in a Banana
Republic where one Administration comes
in and arrests and and you know punishes
people from the previous one and then
another Administration comes in and we
do it the other away and then that way
and that way and that way and we end
this end up on this seesaw of insanity
because you'll get no good people in
government and that's kind of where
we're at right now anyway so my my
preference at this point would be I
don't see a way that Merrick Garland's
going to be punished I don't see a way
fauci's going to be punished but you
keep having the hearings because you
keep exposing it and then hopefully
people start voting a different way and
then maybe over time that's how you un
calcified the machine Lewin says did you
do you find any of Trump's comments
about desantis's integrity relating to
his support of rhino anti-magalinings
even remotely concerning I understand
that actions speak louder than words but
why run away from CPAC why not lean in
well let me address the second part
first I don't know that well I'm sure he
was invited to CPAC I was invited to
CPAC I had other things the guy's been
traveling all over he has the book
release you know CPAC just isn't as big
and influential as it once was like it
was it was pretty empty this year you
watch some of those speeches they were
pretty pretty empty and in those rooms
so they aren't the event itself isn't as
uh
as sort of ubiquitous as it once was
that it would kind of leak into
everything and it also has become a very
Maga focused thing so I don't know how
representative is of The Wider
conservative movement as far as some of
the Trump things where he's saying these
things about DeSantis he's a rhino and a
globalist it's like dude you endorse the
guy twice you live in his State you take
credit for putting him on the map like
these games are not working with him if
you want to make and also if DeSantis is
a rhino Republican name-only uh
globalist then well he's doing
everything we all want so I don't know
what that makes us but he's doing all of
the things that conservatives ever
purport to believe in and is he doing
all of those things in the name of
globalism like come on come on SO Trump
and I've tweeted this out and I got a
lot of hit pushback from from the Trump
people but it's like it's like dude I
voted for you once I like uh I like your
kids I think you've been a net good for
this country and you woke up a gajillion
people but make the case for yourself
instead of the crazy tweets or the truth
social posts about to make the case I'm
the guy who could drain the swamp
DeSantis can't do it because I have
endless resources he doesn't he has
young kids he has other considerations
it's all or nothing with me and I'm
gonna do it and blah blah like that's
the case for Trump that's the case for
Trump make that case but if your case is
DeSantis who hasn't even announced yet
is a rhino and a globalist and I
supported him twice and all it's like
that just does not work I also just
don't think the names work anymore the
sanctimonious or tiny D it's like he's
workshopping these names it feels phony
it feels scripted it feels kind of
Hollywood like it just ain't flying
anymore so I think
look letting them fight it out hopefully
levels up everybody and and right now I
would say between if you look at Trump
and you look at DeSantis and you take
Vivek ramaswamy
you take Nikki Haley has anyone else
officially announced yet it sounds like
Mike Pompeo will I think I think that's
about it for now
uh yeah but back
um the point is guys it's like you're
gonna get a really decent wide net
remember what the Democrats put out
there a couple of years ago with Biden
right you had Pete bootage completely
unqualified no no real set of ideas
behind him other than wokeness you had
two socialists in Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren
um you had who else did they have uh who
else you had Cory Booker who was always
crying you had Kamala Harris who was
polling at zero like you had really just
and then you had Joe Biden right like
the winner of that thing was Joe Biden
but you really I think that's fairly
objective to say this was not the
greatest crop of candidates where right
now the Republicans have some
interesting choices right like DeSantis
obviously is a good candidate Trump you
know what all the positives are right uh
Nikki she's clearly good I know a lot of
people on the Trump side don't like her
but like she's a good sort of I would
say center-right candidate vivex got a
new set of ideas and is a great
communicator so you hopefully you get
some more people in there whether that's
a Ted Cruz or Rand Paul or Tim Scott or
whoever it might be and you get more
people in there and then at the end you
you bludgeon each other and then you
figure out how to coalesce and then and
then we remove this this psychotic woke
monster that this Administration has
become and then to get back to an
earlier question then the federal
government will start working and it
will get off the backs of the states and
this country could run like it was
supposed to I'm a dreamer but I'm not
the only one ladies and gentlemen if you
have not subscribed at rumble.com Ruben
report please do and uh that's it for
today there's no post game show because
of the thing that I told you guys uh
secretly on the post game show yesterday
and I gotta go now so see you later have
a nice day so long sayonara adios Avida
saying I have in my home a a cabin off
space that is completely secure
this is
[Music]
foreign